we are facing alarming trends in the
rising volumes of people illegally
crossing our southwest border or
arriving at our ports of entry without
documents this increased flow presents
currently at our highest levels in over
a decade both a border security and
humanitarian crisis regardless of
anyone's preferred policy outcome the
status quo is unacceptable
sobering new statistics today from the
US Customs and Border Protection in this
fiscal year so far there's been more
than a 300% increase in the number of
family units or people posing his family
units apprehended compared to the same
time last year and in total CBP has
arrested more than two hundred and sixty
eight thousand illegals at our southwest
border just in the last five months put
that in perspective that's almost the
population of Durham North Carolina
which is the 77th most populous city in
America yet the Democrats want to block
President Trump's national emergency
declaration because you know there's no
crisis at the border well this is a
manufactured crisis I think there's a
problem not a crisis a wall is a
colossal waste of money for a crisis
that doesn't exist this is really a
manufactured crisis on many levels
manufactured by the Trump administration
well it's not manufacture unless you
have open borders and yeah they just
come right in even the liberal New York
Times is more concerned about the plight
of the illegals than their threat to our
safety just look at the headline in the
front page today border patrol
facilities put detainees with medical
conditions at risk why is the left
attacking our border agents they are the
ones putting their lives in line every
day trying to protect us the American
people joining me now Howie Kurtz Fox
News media analyst and host of media
busts Sundays right here on fnc and Tim
Ballard a former DHS special agent and
founder of operation underground
railroad which rescues victims from
human smuggling great to have both you
on Howie why does the New York Times
after laying out I want to read part of
this they lay out this harrowing story
about the border and
then they claimed in an editorial as it
doesn't exist as part of what they wrote
let's start with today an average of
2000 200 migrants a day are now crossing
the 1,900 mile border with Mexico many
after grueling journeys that leave them
injured sick or badly dehydrated yet
most of the nation's customs and border
protection facilities along the border
lacks sufficient accommodations staffing
or procedures to thoroughly assess
health needs or to provide more than
basic emergency care and then March 5th
the New York Times Editorial Board says
that national emergency doesn't exist
saying the national emergencies act
doesn't define what an emergency is a
loophole Trump took advantage of
contrary to all the evidence there's
basically not a crisis at the border
well Laura I think the New York Times
news story is a legitimate journalistic
look at a humanitarian crisis which by
the way quotes Kirsten Nielsen is saying
we're doing a moon camel we don't have
the resources which says that many of
the migrants arrive there already have
chronic diseases or they worry why is
that the American taxpayers fault it's
horrible and it's awful and and parents
who do this I understand why they're
doing it but they're putting their
children at risk and themselves are
we're going to talk to Tim about at risk
of traffic being trafficked themselves
rightfully underscores how much of the
media are totally focused on this side
of the story this is their murder night
not the broader emergency the president
trapped the American people by other
people and enables them many of them to
blame every bad thing that happens to
migrants on the Trump administration
right but even in Tim I'm trying to get
at this they lay out what is an
emergency situation now they can blame
Trump for it and say it's all Trump's
fault that we don't have five-star
facilities at our border hotels full
concierge medical care you know English
language lesson but we do have a lot of
good stuff that helping people but they
lay this out so in their description it
is an emergency they just want to throw
more money at it look I look at this
through the eyes of kids that's my job I
spend 12 years on that border by the way
as an undercover operator special agent
looking for children who are being
trafficked into the United States to be
sold to our American pedophiles this is
an emergency to these children they are
coming in here they're being dragged by
tow there's a 300 percent
increase in adults bringing children who
aren't there kids yeah
so these kids are vulnerable to being
trafficked 93% of these kids that we're
recovering or outside the port of entry
okay so where are they going a lot of
them are being used as pawns because we
have their strange policy in common but
the Congress passed that says bring a
kid and you can claim a you can claim
you know right again the Democrats and
Republicans both I blame both from the
angle they are both responsible both
parties for not addressing this Asylum
issue right that as long as you come in
with someone you say is related to you
you cannot be sent home you're not
basically children are resettled here
even if they're temporarily you know for
a short period of time now separated but
they are both settled here together
unless you can somehow figure out
they're not related where where is our
Congress no drops the problem yeah it's
in devising smugglers but but think of
this think like a criminal right you
bring a kid across and if you're caught
you can say you know asylum you know I
could to stay here but we know that
they're not doing that all of them
they're taking these kids and they're
selling them into our sex markets here
in the United States and so we have to
control the movements I bought a wall a
barrier controls the movement so we can
identify who's coming in and save these
kids do the eyes are the kids I see this
save the kids yeah there's the children
aspect the suffering aspect the health
aspect and a lot of people watching
tonight tonight are our guy like look
what we have I say this we have two
blocks from where we are broadcasting
every night we drive we drive home and
there are seven eight people on the
street it's freezing out tonight yeah
these are these are appear to be
American citizens and they're on the
street 500 yards from the nation's
capitol and we're and it's sad it's
horrible but a lot of Americans watch
and I go why don't we why are we putting
all of our resources on helping people
who need to be able to thrive in their
own countries the part of it as much as
it's sad it's sad two blocks from here
yes sad what's happening with Tim Tims
documented all them you see in on North
Capitol Street the part of the border
situation of the media minimize is the
illegal immigrants who get through and
sometimes cause as we well no problems
for American families but at the same
time you know you
said Democrats are trying to block
president Trump's emergency declaration
well then that appears to be enough
Republican defections in the Senate that
that's gonna go with the president it'll
be vetoed i Ashton it doesn't surprise
me one bit why does it not surprise me
like we're not we're going beyond the
headlines here you dig into the beyond
the headlines every day and how will you
do such a great job this is about what
has always happened with these two
parties Republicans love to have the
cheap labor flowing in for businesses
because they hate this the worst thing
for American businesses is when we just
start growing up sorry but they want to
keep a downward pressure on wages the
more people coming in the lower the
wages can be in certain sectors and that
Democrats and I want to play this for
Nancy Pelosi an see Pelosi I believe
today in an interview about what it kind
of tells what the Democrats motives are
let's watch these newcomers make America
more American and we want them when they
come here to be fully part of our system
and that means not suppressing the vote
of our newcomers to America she's
talking about legal immigrants we want
every right but this is going wave
forward I mean we have Democrats pushing
to legalize illegal immigrants to vote
even if they're not citizens that they
should be able to vote that is a new
movement building slowly in localities
and cities that's what this is about
votes for Democrats cheap workers for
Republicans I mean while kids are being
hurt as tim has documented and the
American people is okay how much more
money don't have to spend the challenge
for the price is billions if challenged
for the price is to focus on all sides
of this crisis and not be swept away by
one faction or another's political I
agree but why do they not do front page
articles in the New York Times Howie not
that you speak with them more about you
know what's happened with with the
illegal immigrant crime in the United
States that they I was oh well they
commit less crime than native-born
people well that's the same old troop it
doesn't feel like less crime when you
don't have a husband to go home do you
don't have a brother or a daughter or
someone's been trafficked
why don't you getting enough help from
the from Capitol Hill on what you're
doing I mean you get some help but you
know I'm already helping we we are
getting help from from I'll say from the
Utah
Gatien they've come strong senator hatch
senator Lee congressman Curtis we just
got some bills passed that we brought to
them they passed the bills President
signed them into into law January bills
that will help us work internationally
to stuff it's got to be a comprehensive
approach because these kids are
trafficked internationally almost
800,000 a year
what's a typical man mostly men right a
typical man is there an age that that
engages in this disgusting despicable
crits the hardest thing because there is
no profiler it's scary they're there
they're professionals or they're
educators they're everybody we've
arrested law enforcement officers and
that's and you can't detect it's very
difficult that's why we have to be
proactive as a nation to find these kids
but what we have a 300 percent increase
of adults with people they say are
related to them and they're not how do
we track that down we're doing DNA tests
of course we're not it's a problem both
of you that's an issue I killed very
much about for the American people and
humanitarian financial otherwise thank
you so much